and we're back back into part two we
left off at we're getting GLM for doing
3d math OpenGL mathematics so basically
what this does is it's a just a little
header library that has a bunch of math
functions and it lines up with GLSL
which is the OpenGL shader language so
you can do your stuff in C++ or in GLSL
and it's the same so you can just like
makes a nicer for pass and stuff to the
graphics card back and forth so we want
to go ahead and grab this where's the
download it's right here so I'm going to
save this
into my
downloads
and we're just gonna open her up extract
at all
nothing to compile here of course it's
just a header so I think we've had to
compile so far is GL fw which is our
windowing system next we're gonna get
this STV image for loading textures I
think it's header only as well and image
on this guy there's other ways to do
this
like I think people also you can people
use other image loading and stuff too
like STL as a image loader so you could
use that one theory instead that's the
cool thing about this is
it's just really small
Oh a lot of stuff here I think I only
need this
but some of this might be pretty nice
I'll have to look into it mark for now I
am just going to do the image
so I think that's all I need
okay so yeah this is important you have
to make something for this to compile
into it's sort of interesting
we're gonna go ahead and so I went to
Rahl now I'm gonna hit ctrl D no control
s
waiting for the safe dialogue control s
no
well I suppose the other way to do this
is to select all
do a copy do it with some program I
guess like notepad plus plus should be
able to do it just paste it all in there
Oh No 7,000 line file geez
okay
so I think basically what this does this
STV image is it has all the algorithms
you need to load in a bunch of different
types of images on pngs bitmaps JPEGs
etc etc so it's just all done in one in
the file which is pretty nice it's going
to do a save I'm gonna put in my
downloads call it STV image dot H
sounds pretty roundabout way of saving
this file but it's the job done so there
it is
okay we got that now the last thing is a
simp for loading meshes and models a
simp I'm gonna go ahead and get a simp
real quick cuz then you just compile it
for your version there's a lot of work
being done on this
okay so we cloned the master we should
be able to do this let's just download
the zip all right and we're gonna work
off the master
there's the master
we'll go back to see make
and we'll do this thing
whatever you've any downloads
there's master
oh I should probably actually go into it
you know I don't good and we're going to
make that build folder go into it
okay
and we'll configure
is is configuring
we'll do a little reading I know how
much they make um 126 a month really
that's it for this giant of a project
expect a little bit more 120 bucks a
month to maintain this massive library
that millions of people use probably a
little surprised okay so there we did
that configure we did that setup and now
we just want to go into it going to
build find that solution we configured
for 2019 so
okay go here
build-it
okay good
for succeeded
boom all right much better
okay here we go
ten debug though that's how we were in
release Oh No
we need to compile it as a release okay
hold the phone
we need to make sure its release in
64-bit that's actually rather important
so we're gonna go back in here
or this
you know that bill reopen the solution
not 2017
I'm getting tired of started making it
make silly mistakes okay open with 2019
I forgot to change these up here I think
yeah I need to change this to release go
back down here I need to do it clean
so that's why I wasn't finding it I was
looking for this release folder and
we're gonna go and build it all right so
this is all my what I mean debugs nice
if you're
the bugs nice if I was like working on
on this asset importer because I'd be
debugging it and trying to fix it but
I'm not trying to I'm just trying to use
it so that's why I want the release
version and not the debug
the bug will just be bigger compiling
stuffs not too bad once you get used to
it
these guys have it all set up
all right still chugging away just
checking if I got any any new happenings
even got an unreal loader apparently
Terrigen loader best he a loader SN
loader oh my god this dragon on
there's gonna be a monolith of a video
to edit okay succeeded at least 64 get
code was it in code yeah code release
okay so this is what we need so we're
good a simp is now ready yeah it sees it
okay I'm gonna stop here or essentially
ready to start coding up the project
we've got pretty much everything that we
that we wanted to get going
we've got it all set up we need we do
need to do the linking also you do
linking for a sim so anything that you
compile like that you also have to link
and that is in the properties is under
linker somewhere
and you basically point it to those
libraries so we'll probably cover that
at the begin in the next video
yeah the next part and amen this is this
is what being a dev is like if you're
not using unity or unreal and you want
to do your own custom stuff this is
where you're at
alright peace out